I promised you that I'd give you some
more Pythagorean theorem problems so I
will now give you some more Pythagorean
theorem problems and once again this is
all about practice let's say I had a
triangle let's say it is well let me
just draw my right triangle oh that's
that's an ugly-looking right triangle
let me draw another one there I just
drew an equally ugly looking right
triangle and if I were to tell you that
this side is 7 this side is 6 and I want
to figure out this side well we learned
in the last presentation
what which of these sides is the
hypotenuse well here's the right angle
so the side opposite the right angle is
the hypotenuse so what we want to do is
actually figure out the hypotenuse so we
know that 6 squared plus 7 squared is
equal to the hypotenuse squared and then
the Pythagorean theorem they use C to
represent the hypotenuse oh well you see
here as well is equal to C squared so
we'll say C equals the length of the
hypotenuse and 36 plus 49 is equal to C
squared
what's 36 plus 49 is 70 it's 85 85 is
equal to C squared or C is equal to the
square root of 85 and this is the part
that most people have trouble with is
actually simplifying the radical so
let's see the square root of 85 can i
factor 85 so it's the product of a
perfect square and another number
let's see 85 is it divisible by 4 so it
won't be difficult I 60 nor any of the
multiples of 4 let's see if it's
divisible but it's the 85 5 goes into 85
how many times it goes into it now
that's not a perfect square either I
don't think
85 can be factored further as a product
of a perfect square and another number
so you might correct me I might be wrong
this might be good exercise for you to
do later but as far as I can tell we
have gotten our answer
the answer here is the square root of 85
and if we actually wanted to estimate
what that is well let's think about it
the square root of 81 is 9 and the
square root of 100 is 10 so it's
someplace in between nine and 10 and
it's probably a little bit closer to
nine so it's nine point something
something something and that's a good
reality check that makes sense if the
side is six the side of seven nine point
something something something makes
sense for the sign of that length let me
give you another problem let's say that
this is 10 and this is 3 what is this
side first let's identify our hypotenuse
well we have our right angle here so the
side opposite the right angle is the
hypotenuse and it's also the longest
side so it's 10 so 10 squared is equal
to the sum of the squares of the other
two sides is equal to 3 squared and
let's just call this a wicked
opportunity plus a squared well this is
100 is equal to 9 plus a squared or a
squared is equal to C 100 minus 9 a
squared is equal to 91 so a is equal to
the square root of 91 and I don't think
that can be simplified further either C
3 doesn't go into it under is 91 a prime
number I'm not sure as far as I know
we're done with this problem let me do
let me give you another problem and
actually this time I'm going to include
one extra step just to confuse you
because I think you're getting this a
little bit too easily let's say I have a
triangle and once again we're dealing
all with right triangles now I never
never even attempt to use the
Pythagorean theorem unless you know for
a fact that it's a right triangle
in this example we know that this is a
right triangle if I were to tell you the
length of this side is five and if I
were to tell you that the this angle is
45 degrees can we figure out the other
two sides of this triangle well we can't
use the Pythagorean theorem directly
because the Pythagorean theorem tells us
that if we have a right triangle and we
know two of the sides that we can figure
out the third side here we have a right
triangle and we only know one of the
sides so we can't figure out the other
two just yet but maybe we could use this
extra information right here this 45
degrees to figure out another side and
then we'd be able to use the Pythagorean
theorem well we know that the angles in
a triangle add up to 180 degrees
oh hopefully you know that the angles in
a triangle add up to 180 degrees if you
don't it's my fault because I haven't
taught you that already so let's figure
out what what what the angles of this
triangle add up to well I mean we know
they add up to 180 but using that
information we could figure out what
this angle is right because we know this
angle is 90 this angle is 45 so we say
45 let's call this angle X I'm trying to
make it messy okay 45 plus 90 all right
this just implies this is a 90-degree
angle plus X is equal to 180 degrees and
that's because the angles in a triangle
always add up to 180 degrees so if we
just solve for X we get here we get 135
135 that's a 5 plus X is equal to 180
subtract 135 from both sides we get X is
equal to 45 degrees interesting X is
also 45 degrees so we have a 90 degree
angle and two 45 degree angles now I'm
going to give you another theorem that's
not named after the religion of a
religion or the founder of religion I
actually don't think this this theorem
has a name at all but it's the it's the
fact that if I have a triangle to draw
another triangle out here
we're two of the base angles are the
same and when I say a base angle I just
mean two angles if these two angles are
the same let's call it a they're both a
then the sides that they don't share
right these angles share this side right
but if we look at the sides that they
don't share we know that these sides are
equal I forgot what we call this in
geometry class maybe I'll look it up in
another presentation Allah I'll let you
know but I got this far without knowing
what it what the name of the theorem is
but just and it makes sense you almost
you don't even need me to tell you that
how could I draw this angle
if if I were to change one of these
angles the length would also change or
another way to think about it the only
way I don't want to confuse you too much
but you can visually see that if these
two sides are the same then these two
angles are going to be the same if you
changed one of these sides lengths then
the angles will also change or the
angles will not be equal anymore but
I'll leave you that I'll leave that for
you to think about but just take my word
for it right now that if two angles and
a triangle are equivalent then the sides
that they don't share are also equal in
length right so make sure you remember
not the side that they share because I
can't be equal to anything it's the side
that they don't share is equal are equal
in length so here we have an example
where we have two equal angles
they're both 45 degrees so that means
that the sides that they don't share
this is a side they share right both
angles share this side so that means
that the side that they don't share are
equal so this side is equal to this side
and I think you might be experiencing an
aha moment right now well if this side
is equal to this side we already gave
you at the beginning this problem that
this side is equal to five so then we
know that this side is equal to five and
now we can do the Pythagorean theorem we
know this is the hypotenuse right
hypotenuse so we could say five squared
plus five squared is equal to let's go
say C squared where C is the length of
the hypotenuse well five squared plus
five squared that's just fifty is equal
to C square
and then we get C is equal to the square
root of 50 and 50 is 2 times 25 so C is
equal to 5 square root of 2 interesting
so I think I might have given you a lot
of information there if you get confused
maybe you want to re-watch this video
but on the next video I'm actually going
to give you more information about this
type of triangle which is actually a
very kind of common type of triangle
you'll see in geometry and trigonometry
called a 45-45-90 triangle and it makes
sense why it's called that because it
has 45 degrees 45 degrees and a 90
degree angle and I'll actually show you
a quick way of using that information
that it is a 45 45 90 degree triangle to
figure out the sides if you're given
even one of the sides I hope I will
confuse you too much and I look forward
to seeing you in the next presentation
see you later